A while back, when she first moved to LA, Jessica worked at a pole dancing studio, an exercise place. The pay wasn't great. She was just a receptionist. But there were things about the place that she just loved.
不久前，杰西卡刚搬到洛杉矶时，在一家钢管舞工作室兼职。那地方其实是个健身房。工资不高，她只是个前台。但那个地方有些东西让她非常喜欢。
You know, we got to take classes, the receptionists. And you're in a class with supermodels. I'm not even exaggerating. Cindy Crawford was in my class. And so then it would be--
我们前台也能上课，你可以和超级名模一起上课，我一点都没夸张。辛迪·克劳馥就在我的班上。所以通常会变成——
Wow.
哇。
It would be like Cindy does her dance. And then it'd be like, all right, that was beautiful. Jessica, it's your turn.
辛迪跳完她的舞，然后就会说：好的，跳得真美。杰西卡，轮到你了。
Oh, and you're soloing?
噢，你要独舞吗？
Yeah.
是啊。
You have to solo?
你还得独舞？
Right?
对吧？
What kind of exercise class makes you solo?
什么健身课会让你独舞啊？
Another nice thing about the job, when she checked everyone in for a class and class started, she'd take these long breaks. Once, she strode over to Starbucks. On the way, she saw this poster on a telephone pole. Somebody had found a lost animal.
这份工作的另一个好处是，当她为所有人签到完毕、课程开始后，她就可以享受很长的休息时间。有一次，她溜达到星巴克。路上，她在电线杆上看到一张海报，有人丢了宠物。
And it said "pet found" above a picture of a cat. And I just thought it was so weird that they said "pet found" and not "cat found."
上面写着“寻获宠物”，配的是一张猫的照片。我当时就觉得很奇怪，为什么他们写的是“寻获宠物”而不是“寻获猫”。
Which got her thinking. And when she got back to work, without much to do, she decided to make a poster of her own.
这让她萌生了一个想法。回到工作岗位后，由于没什么事做，她决定自己也做一张海报。
I just wrote "cat found" above two pictures of possums that I had printed off the internet. One of the possums looks like he's crouching, disturbed by an invasive camera lens. And then the other possum is hissing.
我就写了“寻获猫”，上面贴了两张我从网上打印的负鼠照片。其中一只负鼠看起来像是蹲着，被入侵的镜头惊扰到了。另一只负鼠则在嘶嘶叫。
I'd say the second possum is actually kind of scary. It's bearing its sharp teeth, snarling. And then handwritten underneath, there are bullet points. "Male, no collar, not very friendly. I think he might be scared."
我觉得第二只负鼠其实有点吓人。它露出尖锐的牙齿，咆哮着。下面还手写了几条要点：“雄性，无项圈，不太友好。我觉得它可能吓坏了。”
I said "not housebroken either," which I drew a sad face next to.
我说“还没被驯化”，并在旁边画了一个难过的表情。
And then it says, "Found on Sunset Boulevard. If he is yours, please call," and then a phone number.
上面还写着：“在日落大道发现。如果是你的猫，请致电”，接着是一个电话号码。
Yes, my phone number.
没错，是我的电话号码。
She made a few copies, less than a dozen, and put them up around her neighborhood. The idea that some hapless, well-meaning person would put up a poster like this, thinking that they had a cat, it just seemed so funny to her. She thought it was obvious that it was a joke. She really didn't expect the calls.
她印了几份，不到一打，贴在了社区周围。一想到会有好心但倒霉的人看到这张海报，以为真的捡到了一只猫，她就觉得特别好笑。她认为这明显是个恶作剧，压根没想到会有人打电话。
Within two days, my phone just wouldn't stop ringing. And I'm not exaggerating about that. I had to turn my phone off because it was just constantly, constantly, constantly ringing.
两天之内，我的电话响个不停。我一点都没夸张。我不得不关机，因为它真的是没完没了地响。
Hi. I just saw a poster. It says "cat found."
喂。我刚看到一张海报。上面写着“寻获猫”。
I'm calling in regards to the sign you have about the cat found.
我打电话是关于你那个“寻获猫”的牌子。
I'm calling about your "cat found" sign. And I'm just wondering, are you serious? Because I don't think that's a cat.
我打电话是关于你的“寻获猫”标语。我想问问，你是认真的吗？因为我觉得那不是猫。
And then when I started listening to the voicemails, it was kind of like this very unscientific, I would say, social experiment. Because you could really lock the calls into three groups. And the largest group of people were actually very kindly just calling to tell me that it wasn't a cat and that it was a possum.
当我开始听语音留言时，这就像是一个很不科学的社会实验。因为你可以把这些电话分成三类。最大的一群人真的很善良，只是打电话告诉我那不是猫，而是负鼠。
I just wanted to let you know that the picture that you have is of a possum and not a cat. So you're going to want to call animal control because it could have rabies.
我只是想告诉你，你海报上的照片是负鼠，不是猫。你应该联系动物管制中心，因为它可能携带狂犬病毒。
I'm kind of a wildlife guy. And that's a possum, a male possum. And you probably want to release that.
我算是野生动物专家。那是负鼠，一只雄性负鼠。你最好把它放生。
I'm not sure if it's a joke or real, but I'm sure you know by now probably it was a possum and should probably let it out so it's not in your house destroying everything. And hopefully it doesn't have rabies, and hopefully you didn't get hurt, didn't bite you.
我不确定这是恶作剧还是真的，但我肯定你现在应该知道那是负鼠了，最好把它放走，以免它在屋里搞破坏。希望它没得狂犬病，也希望你没受伤，没被咬到。
And it was like they were usually concerned for my well-being or the well-being of the animal.
他们通常是在关心我或者关心这只动物的安危。
You probably just want to get rid of it, let it go or throw it away. But all right, God bless. Take care.
你可能只想摆脱它，放走它或者扔掉它。好吧，上帝保佑。保重。
Anyway, that was nice of you to try to help a poor little soul like that.
不管怎样，你能尝试帮助这种可怜的小生命，真是好心。
So I would say 70% of the people who called were just calling out of the kindness of their own heart and concerned. And then maybe 20% were calling like they were in on the joke, and so calling to say, that's my cat.
所以我想，70%的人打电话纯粹是出于好心和关怀。大概有20%的人好像是在配合这个恶作剧，所以打电话过来说：那是我的猫。
You have my cat. You have my cat. His name is Giorgio.
你捡到了我的猫。那是我的猫，它叫乔治。
And then would make up a story about their cat or pretend to cry because they miss their cat.
然后编造关于他们猫的故事，或者假装哭泣，因为他们想念自己的猫。
Like this next guy, who-- the sound quality, this isn't so great. He says it's his cat, and the cat is a really gentle spirit.
就像下一个人，音频质量不太好。他说那是他的猫，而且那只猫性格非常温柔。
He's a really, really, really gentle spirit, but his behavior is erratic. So he loves to sleep in the same bed with people, but he can get a little aggressive. So you got to thump him in the nose.
它是一个非常、非常、非常温柔的灵魂，但行为有些古怪。它喜欢和人睡在同一张床上，但有时会有点攻击性。所以你得弹它的鼻子。
"You've got to thump him in the nose," he's saying.
“你得弹它的鼻子，”他是这么说的。
Just thump him with your knuckle.
就用指关节弹它一下。
Clearly very bad advice. Jessica says maybe this guy is just trying to mess with her. Which brings us to the last of her three categories of callers, making up maybe 10% of all calls, she says.
显然这是个糟糕的建议。杰西卡说，也许这人只是想捉弄她。这就带出了第三类来电者，大概占了总通话的10%，她说。
They're the ones who are mean and not in on the joke. They're calling to call you an idiot.
这些人很刻薄，并没有参与恶作剧。他们打电话纯粹是为了骂你是白痴。
Yeah, that cat? It's a possum, you fricking [BLEEP].
嘿，那只猫？那是只负鼠，你这个混蛋。
Hi. I think you found my cat. I was just calling in reference to your poster. If you could call me back, that'd be really great. Oh, and by the way, you're a fucking idiot. That's not a cat. Bye.
喂。我想你找到了我的猫。我打电话是关于你的海报。如果你能回电，那就太好了。对了，顺便说一句，你是个彻头彻尾的蠢货。那根本不是猫。再见。
Jessica ended up getting hundreds of calls from all over the country because someone posted her "cat found" sign on the internet. And the fact that overwhelmingly most people who called wanted to help her out and warn her it was possum, and that only 10% of the callers went out of their way to be mean. She says normally, she thought, people as a whole were not so great. She wasn't somebody who had much faith in humanity.
最终，因为有人把她的“寻获猫”海报发到了网上，杰西卡接到了全国各地打来的数百个电话。绝大多数打电话的人都是想帮助她，提醒那是负鼠，只有10%的人特意跑来刻薄骂人。她说，本来她觉得人总体上不怎么样。她不是那种对人性抱有太多希望的人。
I mean, for good reason.
我是说，这有充分的理由。
Sure.
确实。
But so yeah. So I was a cynical person, but then when the calls started coming in and the majority of them were so nice, it was very surprising to me.
所以，是的。我曾是个愤世嫉俗的人，但当这些电话打进来，大部分人都那么友善时，我感到非常惊讶。
It's interesting your conclusion to this is like, oh, people are surprisingly nice.
你得出这个结论很有意思，就像是说：噢，人们出奇地友善。
Yeah.
是的。
You never hear that lesson.
你可从没听过这样的教训。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
I feel like so many things in life really come down to if you think people are nice or not, if people are going to try to do the right thing. I feel like it runs all through our politics. It runs through personal situations, whether or not you think people are going to basically do the right thing and be kind most of the time.
我觉得生活中的很多事情最终都归结于你是否认为人们是善良的，他们是否会试图做正确的事。我觉得这贯穿了我们的政治生活。这在个人处境中也一样，看你是否认为人们在大多数时候会基本做正确的事并保持友善。
Right. What do you think? Do you think they are going to do the right thing and be kind?
没错。你怎么看？你认为他们会做正确的事并保持友善吗？
Oh my god. Of course. I'm so squarely on the side of like, oh, yeah, most people are going to try to do the right thing most of the time. But I definitely get into lots of conversations all the time with people in my personal life and just elsewhere who are just like, oh, of course that's not true. Of course that person is trying to rip you off. Of course they didn't mean well when they did this.
噢，天哪。当然。我坚定地站在这一边，觉得大多数人在大多数时候都会尝试做正确的事。但我确实经常和个人生活中的人以及其他地方的人进行很多对话，他们会说：噢，那当然不是真的。那个人当然想坑你。他们做这件事时当然没安好心。
Right. When I made the poster, I would say it absolutely surprised me that people wanted to be helpful.
没错。我做那张海报时，人们想要提供帮助的态度确实让我感到惊讶。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on the program, "The Possum Experiment." We have three stories today on our show of people in wildly different situations, puzzling it out. Can we trust people, really? Are people mostly good?
这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目主题是“负鼠实验”。我们节目中有三个关于人们在截然不同的情况下如何摸索的故事。我们真的能信任别人吗？人们本质上是好的吗？
I know that it's such an embarrassingly basic question to be asking, but sometimes you really are in situations where that is the thing you need to figure out. But we don't just ask the question today. We have answers. Stay with us.
我知道这是一个令人尴尬的基本问题，但有时你确实会处于需要搞清楚这一点的境地。今天我们不只是提出这个问题。我们还有答案。请留下来。
Act 1, "Now You See Me." Kiese Laymon's a writer, and he's pretty clear on where he stands on this question, can you usually trust people? He lands squarely in the camp of be skeptical. He says we've all been burned by other people, by institutions. We build up distrust, and distrust protects us.
第一幕，“现在你看见我了”。基斯·莱蒙是一位作家，他对自己在这个问题上的立场很明确：你通常能信任别人吗？他坚定地站在“持怀疑态度”这一阵营。他说我们都被人、被机构伤害过。我们建立起不信任感，而不信任感保护了我们。
Which is the opposite of what Darryl Lennox believes. Darryl's a comedian. He says we're better off trusting that most people have good intentions. Yeah, you run into bad apples, but it's not worth constantly being on guard. This is not, however, what Darryl always believed. In fact, until recently, he was more like Kiese. But then something happened, something big, that changed his mind. Kiese talked to him about it.
这与达里尔·伦诺克斯的信念截然相反。达里尔是一位喜剧演员。他说如果我们相信大多数人都有好的意图，我们会过得更好。是的，你会遇到坏人，但不值得时刻保持警惕。然而，达里尔并不总是这样想的。事实上，直到最近，他都像基斯一样。但后来发生了一件大事，改变了他的想法。基斯和他谈了这件事。
There's a joke that Darryl Lennox tells that I love. He's a comedian, and a lot of his comedy has to do with the absurdities of losing his vision.
达里尔·伦诺克斯讲过一个我非常喜欢的段子。他是个喜剧演员，他的很多喜剧内容都与他失明的荒谬经历有关。
I'm at the baggage claim in Milwaukee, Wisconsin. And all of a sudden, this old Black dude shows up in front of me, goes, hey, man, ain't you a comedian? I go, yes, I am. He goes, I saw you on TV, man-- Conan. Yeah, yeah, that was me. He goes, you's a funny dude. I said, I appreciate it. Thank you. He goes, yeah, you're the real philosophical nigga with the fucked-up eyes [INAUDIBLE].
我在威斯康星州密尔沃基的行李提取处。突然，一个黑人老头出现在我面前，说：嘿，伙计，你不是那个喜剧演员吗？我说：是的，我是。他说：我在电视上看过你——在柯南秀上。我回答：对，那是我。他说：你是个有趣的家伙。我说：谢谢，我很感激。他说：没错，你就是那个眼珠子有点毛病的哲学黑人哥们。
I was like, that is not how I describe myself at all. Yet inarguably accurate, sir. I cannot debate you on this one. He kept going. Yeah, man, you's funny. You're like half Morpheus, half Mr. Magoo. You's a funny motherfucker, man. I was like, half Morpheus, half Mr. Magoo?
我当时想：这根本不是我形容自己的方式。但毫无争议，先生，你说得很准。在这点上我无法反驳你。他继续说：伙计，你挺逗的。你就像一半摩菲斯，一半皮先生。你这个有趣的混蛋。我当时想：一半摩菲斯，一半皮先生？
I love this joke, because this stranger at the baggage claim, who reminds me of all my Newport-smoking uncles in Milwaukee, is recognizing Darryl and letting him know it. It's like that knowing nod I've gotten my entire life from older Black men strangers, often with a slow shake of a head and a mild smirk.
我喜欢这个段子，因为行李领取处的这个陌生人让我想起了我在密尔沃基所有抽新港烟的叔叔们，他在认出达里尔并告诉他。这就像我一生中从陌生的黑人老者那里得到的点头示意，通常伴随着缓慢的摇头和轻微的坏笑。
Yeah, I took it as a compliment, is why I said it on stage that night, because it was really deep to me, the fact that he could sum me up that quickly.
是的，我把它当成恭维，这就是为什么那天晚上我在舞台上说了出来，因为他能如此迅速地总结出我的特点，这对我来说非常深刻。
Darryl always had problems with his vision. So growing up, he was able to see well enough to play point guard on his basketball teams in high school and college. He went completely blind in his left eye two decades ago, when he was 33. And then in 2018, he became allergic to his glaucoma meds and started to lose the vision in his other eye.
达里尔视力一直有问题。所以在他成长过程中，他能看清东西，足以在高中和大学的篮球队里打控球后卫。二十年前，也就是他33岁时，他的左眼彻底失明。然后到了2018年，他对青光眼药物过敏，开始失去另一只眼睛的视力。
Be two years ago this month. I don't remember the day, but I went to bed, and I could still look and see through a very small corner window of my eye and read a text message that had come in, and then didn't respond to it. And then I go to sleep. I wake up the next morning, and that window was shut. It was just straight black.
就在这个月的两年前。我不记得确切日期了，但我上床睡觉时，还能通过眼睛的一小块角落看东西，读了一条发来的短信，然后没回。接着我就睡着了。第二天早上醒来，那扇窗户关上了。眼前是一片漆黑。
And then I laid in the bed, kept opening my eyes and closing to see what's going to happen. And then I didn't want to stay in the bed too much longer, because then that's when the fear steps in. So I got up, felt my wall all the way to the bathroom. And I stood in the bathroom, tried to stare at myself in the mirror. I just kept turning the light on and off to see if I could register any light coming on, and nothing happened.
然后我躺在床上，不停地睁眼闭眼，看会发生什么。然后我不想在床上待太久，因为恐惧开始蔓延。所以我起身，摸着墙走到洗手间。我站在洗手间，试着在镜子里盯着自己看。我一直开灯又关灯，看能不能感知到光，但什么也没发生。
So I stared in the mirror. And I felt for the toothbrush, and I brushed my teeth. And I said, you're not allowed to cry. I did my affirmations. I did my affirmations.
我盯着镜子。我摸索着牙刷，刷了牙。我说：不许哭。我做了自我肯定。我做了自我肯定。
I'm the best of all time. I'm the best comic alive. I'm the funniest MF on the planet. And I'm going to change this world, boom. So let's go to work. So I start feeling my way around the house. I just start riding the walls--
我是史上最棒的。我是活着的最棒的喜剧演员。我是这星球上最有趣的混蛋。我要改变这个世界，轰。所以，开工吧。于是我开始摸索着在房子里走动。我开始沿着墙壁走——
Wow.
哇。
--sitting down, and figuring out how to use my phone. You can't anticipate absolute blackness. There's just no way to anticipate it. You can't practice it. Because even when you close your eyes, you still can--
——坐下来，弄清楚怎么用手机。你无法预料绝对的黑暗。根本无法预料。你无法练习。因为即使闭上眼睛，你仍然可以——
I was about to ask.
我正要问。
There's still light and stuff going on.
仍然会有光之类的东西。
There's a difference between--
这之间有区别——
Yes.
是的。
My eyes are closed right now. That is not what you're talking about.
我现在的眼睛闭着。那不是你在说的那个。
That's right.
没错。
Before he lost his sight, Darryl described himself as a fighter, nearly completely distrusting of the motives of strangers. He stayed clear of them as best he could. But after he completely lost his sight, that changed. He felt like he had to trust strangers now, that he was getting into situations just getting from one place to another, where he thought he had no choice. This, of course, isn't how everyone who's blind moves through the world.
在失明之前，达里尔形容自己是个斗士，几乎完全不信任陌生人的动机。他尽可能地避开他们。但彻底失明后，这一切改变了。他觉得现在必须信任陌生人，他在从一个地方去另一个地方的过程中，经常陷入他认为别无选择的境地。当然，这并不是每个盲人行走在这个世界上的方式。
Strangers started approaching Darryl in a new way too. Realizing he was blind, they would come up to him at bars, restaurants, and airports, and start telling him secrets, lots of secrets, all the secrets. He told me he'd have conversations like this eight or 10 times a week sometimes.
陌生人开始以一种新的方式接近达里尔。意识到他失明后，他们会在酒吧、餐厅和机场走过来，开始告诉他秘密，很多秘密，所有的秘密。他告诉我，有时一周会有八到十次这样的对话。
It's like a confessional, like a confessional. People get close enough to me and they start confessing all this stuff. One lady, I was listening to a text message on my phone. She goes, put your phone down, and grabbed my phone. I go, what are you doing? She says, put it down. Life is short. I go, I know. I know, but I'm blind. And I stop to listen to my phone.
这就像忏悔，就像忏悔。人们靠近我，开始坦白所有这些事。有位女士，我当时在手机上听短信。她说：把手机放下，然后抢走了我的手机。我问：你在干什么？她说：放下它。人生短暂。我说：我知道。我知道，但我失明了。我停下来听我的手机。
She goes, listen, I'm dying. I have two months, and I want to enjoy as much as possible. So now I have to stop and listen so that she can have a complete, fully attentioned listened to conversation about her mortality. And so I asked her the questions about, are you prepared, or what are you afraid of? I have these conversations with people all the time.
她说：听着，我快死了。我只剩下两个月了，我想尽可能多地享受生活。所以现在我必须停下来，听她讲关于她死亡的完整、全神贯注的对话。所以我问她关于：你准备好了吗，或者你害怕什么？我总是和人们进行这些对话。
Strangers will talk to Darryl about their partner's cheating, their money issues, their brutal divorces. An ex-Catholic priest told him he liked to have sex with straight men. Some dude told him how he once robbed a bank in Seattle and got away with it. Each confession unprovoked, completely unsolicited, and by the way, mostly from white strangers and all from folks who are not blind.
陌生人会和达里尔谈论伴侣的出轨、金钱问题、残酷的离婚。一位前天主教神父告诉他，他喜欢和直男发生性关系。有个家伙告诉他曾经在西雅图抢劫银行并侥幸逃脱。每一个坦白都是突如其来的，完全没有被要求，而且顺便说一句，大多来自白人陌生人，并且都是视力正常的人。
Darryl says people do this because since he can't see them. He can't judge them. I wonder if these strangers are leaning violently almost on that Morpheus idea, that a blind Black man is some kind of oracle, a soothsayer, a wise Black superhuman here to save us all. I wanted to try my best to not be like that. And yet, as we talked about strangers, I wanted badly to confess to Darryl how terrified I've always been of them and how COVID made this worse, made me see every stranger as someone I might kill or be killed by, how two years into the pandemic I've been nudged from being slightly anti-social into a complete recluse.
达里尔说人们这样做是因为他看不见他们。他无法评判他们。我好奇这些陌生人是否几乎强烈地依赖于那种摩菲斯的想法，即一个失明的黑人男性是某种先知、占卜者，是一个来拯救我们所有人的智慧黑人超人。我极力想让自己不那样。然而，当我们谈论陌生人时，我非常渴望向达里尔坦白我对他们一直以来的恐惧，以及新冠疫情如何加剧了这种恐惧，让我把每个陌生人都看作是一个我可能会杀掉或被其杀掉的人。疫情两年后，我从轻微的社交恐惧变成了一个彻底的隐士。
I didn't say any of that to him. But it was why I was interested in talking to him in the first place, because his experience of the last two years has been the complete opposite. He went blind at the beginning of the pandemic, and since then he's more embracing of strangers, more open to them than he's ever been in his life. I listened to all of his albums and was intrigued, if not fully convinced, by his musings on that and on the relationships between blindness and Blackness. Here's one of those.
我没有对他讲这些。但这正是我最初想和他谈话的原因，因为他过去两年的经历与我完全相反。他在疫情开始时失明了，从那以后，他比一生中任何时候都更拥抱陌生人，对他们更开放。我听了他所有的专辑，对他的思考以及盲目与黑人身份之间的关系感到好奇，如果不是完全信服的话。这里有一个例子。
Here's something that I philosophized this little trip. It's a trip for me. This fucks with my head a little bit. My blindness is diffusing the scariness of my Blackness.
这里有一点我在这趟旅程中思考出来的道理。这对我来说是一次旅行。这让我的头脑有些混乱。我的盲目消解了我作为黑人的可怕感。
That was one of my secret weapons to be a big brother, and people get nervous. Oh, fuck. There's a big Black guy. Watch out. That shit is powerful. It was a thrill.
这曾是我身为大个子黑人的秘密武器之一，人们会感到紧张。噢，该死。有个大黑个子。小心点。那玩意儿很有威力。那是一种刺激。
Once people find out that I can't see, my Blackness is out the window. They treat me like I'm a Make-a-Wish baby. Uh oh, watch out. There's a big Black guy. Oh, he just walked into the broom closet. OK, no worries.
一旦人们发现我看不见，我的黑人身份就不再是关注点了。他们对待我像对待“愿望成真”的孩子一样。噢哦，小心点。有个大黑个子。噢，他刚才走进了扫帚柜。好吧，没关系。
I got the joke, but I wasn't sure if I was supposed to laugh at the broom closet trope or nod up and down slowly, signaling that I was aware of the broom closet trope. Darryl told me this one confession story that was also one of these instances where he could see his blindness diffusing his Blackness in real time. It was about a guy he bumped into by accident as he sat down at a bar. The guy seemed unusually mad about it, even after Darryl apologized and explained he couldn't see.
我听懂了这个段子，但不确定我是否应该嘲笑“扫帚柜”的梗，或者缓慢地点头，表示我意识到了这个梗。达里尔讲了另一个坦白故事，这也是他能实时看到盲目消解黑人身份的例子之一。那是关于他在酒吧坐下时偶然撞到的一个家伙。即使在达里尔道歉并解释他看不见之后，那个人似乎仍然异常愤怒。
So I felt this hostility, energy just funky right away. So I go, what's your name? He goes, Bob. I go, Bob, I'm Darryl. And I said, come on, man, let me buy you a beer.
我立刻感觉到这种敌意，那种糟糕的能量。所以我说：你叫什么名字？他说：鲍勃。我说：鲍勃，我是达里尔。我说：拜托，伙计，让我请你喝杯啤酒吧。
Then he goes, so you're really blind? And I say, yeah. And he goes, what's that like? I said, well, I have to trust everybody.
然后他说：所以你真的失明了？我说：是的。他问：那是什么感觉？我说：好吧，我必须信任每个人。
He goes, I would never let that happen. He goes, I'm a cop. I go, well, wait. So if I have to trust everybody, you have to wake up and trust nobody? He goes, that's exactly right.
他说：我绝不会让那种事发生。他说：我是个警察。我说：等一下。所以如果我必须信任每个人，你必须每天醒来后谁都不信任？他说：没错，就是这样。
Bob the cop went on to confess how being so vigilantly mistrustful was taking a toll on him, and he wasn't sure if he could keep doing it.
名叫鲍勃的警察继续坦白这种高度不信任感如何让他付出了代价，他不确定自己还能不能坚持下去。
And he goes, I'll be honest with you. He goes, my name isn't Bob. I go, I knew you was lying. Ain't nobody named Bob. Ain't nobody named damn Bob.
他说：老实跟你说吧。他说：我其实不叫鲍勃。我说：我就知道你在撒谎。没人叫鲍勃。根本没人叫该死的鲍勃。
So I said, well, what's your name? He said it was Kyle. And he goes, I'll be honest with you. He goes, when you sat down, I immediately got my guard up. I go, because I'm Black? He goes, yeah.
所以我问：那你叫什么名字？他说他叫凯尔。他说：我老实跟你说吧。他说：当你坐下时，我立刻提高了警惕。我问：因为我是黑人？他说：是的。
He goes, I'm always on the lookout for it. And he goes, now-- I go, so now that I'm blind and Black, you don't feel threatened or anything? He goes, I wasn't threatened. I'm just on the lookout for stuff all the time.
他说：我一直在提防这种情况。我说：那现在我既失明又是黑人，你就不觉得受威胁了吗？他说：我没受威胁。我只是总是对事情保持警惕。
Wow.
哇。
The cop formerly known as Bob wasn't just telling on himself. To me, he was telling on his entire profession. Darryl told me that when they finished talking, the cop hugged him tightly and did not want to let go.
以前叫鲍勃的警察不只是在出卖自己。对我来说，他是在出卖他的整个职业。达里尔说，当他们谈完时，那个警察紧紧拥抱了他，不想松手。
That doesn't happen if I'm not blind. And then I sense his hostility. I'm like, oh, this cracker-ass dude is on some shit, and I got to be careful of him. He's going to be careful of me. And we have a conversation about something, just stereotypical dumb stuff. But now, because that door has opened where he's not being judged, he can apologize for judging me. Now we get to be on the same plane in existence.
如果我不失明，这事就不会发生。我感觉到他的敌意。我在想：噢，这个白人混蛋又在搞什么鬼，我得小心他。他会小心我。我们进行了一次对话，关于一些刻板印象的蠢事。但现在，因为那扇门打开了，他没有被评判，他可以为评判我而道歉。现在我们可以处于同一个存在层面了。
There was something incredibly dizzying and high-key brutal about the "this doesn't happen if I'm blind" part of the story Darryl told me.
达里尔故事中那句“如果我不失明，这事就不会发生”的部分，让人感到极其眩晕且相当残酷。
So the idea that people are treating you with less suspicion now, what does that make you feel, actually, about other people?
所以，人们现在对你减少了怀疑，这对你来说到底感觉如何？
It makes me feel like we're all just one thing away from becoming more connected in humanity. And so if all it took was for me to go blind for you to not feel threatened or weird, maybe we're all just one thing away from realizing we're way more connected than we are disconnected.
这让我觉得我们所有人距离实现人性中更深层的联系只差一步之遥。如果我失明就能让你不再感到威胁或奇怪，也许我们只需要实现某种改变，就能意识到我们之间的联系远比隔阂要多。
That feels like a really positive conclusion. And I don't know that I would see it like that. I would imagine being mad about the hypocrisy or disappointed.
这感觉像是一个非常积极的结论。我不知道我会不会这样看。我可能会对其中的虚伪感到愤怒或失望。
I can't see it. I can't see it anything other than just a positive thing, because I can't-- I'm not going to be a well of somebody else's negativity, to let it contaminate me. It's how I've been training my brain anyway.
我看不出来，除了把它看作积极的一面，我无法以其他方式看待它，因为我不会成为别人负面情绪的井，让它污染我。这反正是我训练大脑的方式。
I've got to be stronger mentally than I've ever been in my life. I've got to be stronger mentally than anybody else. No different than what Obama had to do, or Jesus Christ of Nazareth, or Moses, or Muhammad Ali, or Malcolm X. You've got to be stronger in the head than you've ever been before.
我的心理必须比我一生中的任何时候都更强大。我的心理必须比任何人都强大。这和奥巴马、耶稣基督、摩西、穆罕默德·阿里或马尔科姆·X所做的一样。你必须在头脑中比以往任何时候都更强大。
I asked Darryl about this so many different ways. Like, really? And each time, he responded with almost single-minded positivity. His whole album, Superbloom, is about accepting catastrophe and willing that catastrophe into absolute abundance.
我用各种不同的方式问过达里尔。真的吗？每次，他都以近乎执着的积极态度回应。他的整张专辑《超级绽放》都是关于接受灾难，并意愿将灾难转化为绝对的丰盛。
I got to confess, I didn't get Darryl's refusal to allow any cynicism or even healthy skepticism in until he told me this story about his response to George Floyd's murder. It made me realize how singularly internal his existence is and how singularly protective he must be of that. Darryl said when he heard about the video of George Floyd being murdered, he immediately remembered the sound of George Zimmerman killing Trayvon Martin.
我得坦白，在听到他回应乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀的故事之前，我并不明白达里尔为何拒绝接受任何愤世嫉俗甚至健康的怀疑态度。这让我意识到他的存在是多么单一地内化，他又必须是多么单一地保护这种存在。达里尔说，当他听到乔治·弗洛伊德被谋杀的视频时，他立刻想起了乔治·齐默尔曼杀死特雷沃恩·马丁的声音。
I remember how much hearing Trayvon screaming, that sound. And with limited vision, it lasts longer inside of you. That audio stays in you. When you can't see at all, your imagination can run forever, and your mind is very powerful. So the mind pictures what this dude's face might have looked like. Or was the officer smiling? It's the literal boogeyman effect.
我记得听到特雷沃恩尖叫的声音，那是怎样的声音。而由于视力有限，那声音在你内心持续的时间更长。那段音频会留在你体内。当你完全看不见时，你的想象力可以永远奔跑，你的大脑非常强大。所以大脑会想象这个家伙的脸看起来是什么样。或者警察在笑吗？这是一种文学上的“怪物效应”。
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
It's the thing under the bed.
这就是床底下的那个东西。
I remember watching the video and immediately turning the sound off at the point where George Floyd utters the syllable "Ma" in "Mama." Darryl did not listen to George Floyd call for his mama at all. He knew that the sound of a Black human being accepting death and/or fighting for his life while an officer's knee flattened his throat would take his imagination into places his insides would likely never escape.
我记得看视频时，在乔治·弗洛伊德吐出“妈妈”这个词的“妈”这个音节时，我立刻关掉了声音。达里尔根本没有听乔治·弗洛伊德喊妈妈。他知道一个黑人人类在接受死亡和/或为了生命而战，而警察的膝盖压扁了他的喉咙的声音，会将他的想象力带到他内心可能永远无法逃脱的地方。
While we were talking, I wondered how differently this conversation would have gone if we were alone. I foolishly imagined that it would be just us during our conversation, but that's not how it works. As we talk, there were four other strangers listening in, producers who were neither big, Black, or blind feeding me questions on Zoom, a sound guy standing behind me for three hours in my tiny office. There was the imagined audience of folks who were not big, Black, or blind. It made whatever connection we had feel like a short-lived spectacular performance that neither of us were directing.
当我们交谈时，我好奇如果我们单独相处，这次对话会有什么不同。我愚蠢地想象我们的谈话只会是我们两个人，但事情不是那样的。在我们谈话时，有四个陌生人在听，Zoom上的制片人既不是大个子，也不是黑人，也不是盲人，他们在那儿给我提问；一个录音师在我狭窄办公室里站在我身后三个小时。还有一群想象中的观众，他们也不是大个子黑人盲人。这使我们之间的任何联系都感觉像是一场短暂的壮观表演，而我们两个人都不是导演。
I wonder if you could talk, if you have anything more to say, Darryl, about the way Black men have interacted with you since you've lost your sight.
达里尔，如果你能谈谈，如果你有什么话想说，关于黑人男性在你失明后与你互动的方式。
It's been really-- brothers have this way of understanding without getting too personal, but also not letting you get off easy. They let you know, hey, man, you're still a brother. No matter what you are, you're still one of us.
真的很——兄弟们有一种理解方式，不会太私人化，但也不会让你轻松过关。他们会让你知道：嘿，哥们，你仍然是一个兄弟。不管你是什么样，你仍然是我们的一员。
Like there was this one amateur comedian.
就像那个业余喜剧演员。
So I gave him some notes. He said, damn, man, you funny. He said, all right, man. So I said, all right, bro. He said, all right, Cyclops.
所以我给了他一些建议。他说：该死，伙计，你真幽默。他说：好的，伙计。我说：好的，兄弟。他说：好的，独眼巨人。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah. "All right, Cyclops." And then he bounced.
是的，“好的，独眼巨人。”然后他就溜了。
Wow. [LAUGHS] Wow.
哇。（笑）哇。
So interesting about the Black community now is because I'm blind, I think they think I'm even more Black than I was before.
关于现在的黑人社区，最有趣的是，因为我失明了，我想他们觉得我比以前更像一个黑人了。
Oh, talk to me about that, brother. What does that mean? Why? How?
噢，跟我谈谈那个，兄弟。那是什么意思？为什么？怎么回事？
Because now I'm just my energy, which is just Black. It's not insecurity. It's not I read a lot of books or I speak well or don't speak well. Now I'm just this brother that understands things.
因为现在我只是我的能量，那纯粹是黑人的能量。这不是不安全感。不是我读了很多书，或者我说话好或不好。现在我只是那个理解事物的兄弟。
Though I've been firmly on this side of vision and this side of suspicion my entire life, my relationship with both started to shift immediately after my conversation with Darryl. I tried so hard not to be that goofy man whose life is changed in one interaction with the blind Black dude.
虽然我一生都坚定地站在视觉和怀疑的这一边，但在与达里尔谈话后，我与两者的关系立刻开始动摇。我拼命不让自己成为那个因与失明黑人哥们的互动而改变人生的蠢人。
But the truth is, the day following our conversation, I didn't wait in the parking lot for my neighbors to go in before I got out of my car. I didn't sit on my couch working all day, wondering what it would be like to actually go outside and play. I went to the park near dusk and swung on swings next to strangers for the first time since the pandemic started. While swinging, I kept my mask on and listened again to Darryl's latest album. I kept replaying the first track, where the older brother from Milwaukee recognizes Darryl at the baggage claim.
但事实是，在我们谈话后的第二天，我没有等邻居进屋后再下车。我没有整天坐在沙发上工作，想知道走出户外去玩会是什么感觉。黄昏时分，我去了公园，自疫情开始以来第一次在陌生人旁边荡秋千。荡秋千时，我戴着口罩，又听了一遍达里尔的最新专辑。我反复播放第一首曲子，那是密尔沃基的老哥们在行李提取处认出达里尔的片段。
Yeah, you're the real philosophical nigga with the fucked-up eyes [INAUDIBLE]. I was like, uh--
没错，你就是那个眼珠子有点毛病的哲学黑人哥们。（听不清）我当时想：呃——
That few minutes of swinging next to unmasked strangers, laughing goofily with Darryl's voice in my ears, it didn't make me feel free, or delivered, or fundamentally changed. It made me go home in what feels like a world full of ruin, extremely thankful to be alive, and listen to an unexpected voicemail from a stranger named Darryl. "Man," I texted him back, "I'm so glad we ain't strangers no more."
在不戴口罩的陌生人旁边荡秋千的那几分钟，听着达里尔的声音傻笑，并没有让我感到自由、解脱或从根本上改变。它让我带着一种世界充满废墟的感觉回家，无比感激自己还活着，并听了一条来自陌生人达里尔的出人意料的语音留言。“伙计，”我回信给他，“我真高兴我们不再是陌生人了。”
Kiese Laymon, he's the author of several books, most recently a memoir called Heavy. Coming up, a guy comes to New York City thinking it's a den of iniquity. And then a stranger walks up to him with a very unusual suggestion. Should he take the advice? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
基斯·莱蒙，他是几本书的作者，最近的一本是名为《沉重》的回忆录。接下来，一个家伙来到纽约市，认为这是一个罪恶之城。然后一个陌生人走近他，提出了一个非常不寻常的建议。他该听从这个建议吗？一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目为你揭晓。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, "The Possum Experiment," stories that shed light on the embarrassingly basic question, are most people usually trying to do the right thing? Can they be trusted? We've arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, "Spring Awakening."
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目《负鼠实验》，讲述的故事为那个令人尴尬的基本问题提供了参考：大多数人通常是在试图做正确的事吗？他们值得信任吗？我们来到了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“春天觉醒”。
OK, so one answer to the question "can you trust people to do the right thing" is that you can trust the people in your own group. And you can define that group however you want-- the people you share a religion with, or a nationality, or a race. Or maybe you grew up in the same place, went to the same school. They're the ones who share your values. Everybody else, don't trust them.
好了，对于“你能信任人们做正确的事吗”这个问题，一个答案是你可以在你自己的群体内信任别人。你可以随心所欲地定义那个群体——和你共享宗教、国籍或种族的人。或者也许你在同一个地方长大，上了同一所学校。他们是那些分享你价值观的人。至于其他人，别信任他们。
That's how the person in this next story, Clay Elder, felt about things till one day during a visit to New York City. Elna Baker, tell us what happened.
这就是下个故事里的克莱·埃尔德对事情的看法，直到有一天访问纽约市。埃尔娜·贝克，告诉我们发生了什么。
I've known Clay since we were 15. And when we get together, it's not unusual for us to Mormon out.
我和克莱从15岁就认识了。我们聚在一起时，一起唱摩门教歌是很寻常的事。
Oh, what were they called?
噢，它们叫什么来着？
(SINGING) Book of Mormon Stories. That one?
（唱歌）摩门经故事。那个？
Oh. Well, that one, but-- darn it.
噢。嗯，那个，但是——该死。
Try to remember church songs and other stuff from when we were kids.
试着记住小时候唱的教会歌曲和其他东西。
(SINGING) We believe the Bible to be the word of God, as far as it is translated correctly. We also believe the Book of Mormon to be the word of God.
（唱歌）我们相信《圣经》是上帝的话语，只要它被正确翻译。我们也相信《摩门经》是上帝的话语。
[LAUGHTER]
（笑声）
That's not even a song. It's just words and notes.
那根本不是歌。只是文字和音符。
Clay is gay. As a kid growing up in the Mormon Church, he was taught that practicing homosexuality was akin to incest or bestiality. He hid out in musical theater, which, I know, terrible hiding place. But in Utah, that worked.
克莱是同性恋。作为在摩门教长大的孩子，他被教导说，进行同性恋行为等同于乱伦或兽交。他躲进了音乐剧里，我知道，这是个糟糕的藏身之处。但在犹他州，这管用。
He studied theater at BYU. That's where he learned some of the musicals that Mormons love, the cheesy G-rated shows like Seven Brides for Seven Brothers. He didn't think it was something he would be able to do professionally. Instead, he saw it as a hobby.
他在杨百翰大学学习戏剧。那是他学会摩门教徒喜欢的音乐剧的地方，像《七新娘七兄弟》那样俗气的G级表演。他没认为这是他能专业从事的事。相反，他把它看作爱好。
He did musicals that the Mormon church put on, playing everyone from Joseph Smith, father of Mormonism, to Joseph, father of Jesus, or stepfather. He'd get on stage in front of thousands, help Mary give birth to the Son of God, and then sneak out to gay bars. If he kissed a guy, he'd feel guilty. And then he'd repent, then repeat. It was torture. He knew that a bigger city like New York was where people went to do all the things he wanted to do, but he couldn't imagine going there.
他参与了摩门教会举办的音乐剧，扮演过从摩门教之父约瑟夫·史密斯到耶稣之父或继父约瑟夫等所有人。他会在成千上万观众面前登上舞台，帮助玛丽生下上帝之子，然后溜去同性恋酒吧。如果他亲吻了一个男人，他会感到内疚。然后他会忏悔，接着重演。这是一种折磨。他知道纽约这样的大城市是人们去追求他想做的一切事情的地方，但他无法想象去那里。
New York was evil. It was like the great city that would one day fall.
纽约是邪恶的。它就像终有一天会倒塌的伟大的城市。
The great and spacious building.
伟大而宽敞的建筑。
I knew that's what you were thinking when you said that.
我知道你说那话时心里想的就是这个。
Yeah. I mean, basically, it was.
是的。我是说，基本上，确实如此。
"The great and spacious building" is Mormon code for the wicked outside world. In the Book of Mormon, the people who lived in the great and spacious building dressed in fancy clothes and pointed out their windows at the believers, laughing at us and mocking us. Their goal was to tempt us away from the righteous path. Clay saw New York and the people in it as the great and spacious building.
“伟大而宽敞的建筑”是摩门教暗语，指邪恶的外部世界。在《摩门经》中，居住在伟大而宽敞建筑里的人们穿着华丽的衣服，从窗户指着信徒，嘲笑我们，羞辱我们。他们的目的是诱惑我们离开正义的道路。克莱把纽约和那里的人看作伟大而宽敞的建筑。
And I don't even mean metaphorically. It was. You know, I think that everyone said it was.
我甚至不是指隐喻。它就是。你知道，我想每个人都这么说。
So it took a lot to get Clay to New York, a catastrophic event. It all started when Clay got a boyfriend, his first, and almost no one knew. It was a big deal for him. It meant stepping away from the church, possibly losing his family. After they slept together, they decided to get tested for HIV as a precaution. This was 2006.
所以，让克莱去纽约需要很多力量，一个灾难性的事件。这一切始于克莱有了男朋友，他的第一个男朋友，而且几乎没人知道。这对他来说是一件大事。这意味着远离教会，可能失去家人。他们发生关系后，决定预防性地做艾滋病毒检测。那是2006年。
And we went down to the Utah County Health Center, and we're like, we want HIV tests. And they looked at us like we had three heads.
我们去了犹他州健康中心，说：我们要测艾滋病毒。他们看着我们，就像看怪物一样。
To be openly out like that in Utah County was rare, Clay says. They both did the tests. Clay got called in to get his results-- negative. And then it was his boyfriend's turn.
克莱说，在犹他县那样公开地出柜是很罕见的。他们都做了测试。克莱被叫去拿结果——阴性。然后轮到他男朋友了。
They said his name. He walked back. And I waited. And I waited. And like five minutes went by. And there was no way this was possible. We were just two nice, recently out gay guys in Utah.
他们叫了他的名字。他走进去。我等着。等着。过了五分钟。这根本不可能。我们只是犹他州两个刚出柜的好男孩。
Who are only taking this test because you're so paranoid about being gay.
仅仅是因为你对身为同性恋感到太偏执才做这个测试。
Yeah, yeah. It was truly just to get one out of the way to see what it was like. 24 years old, 23, 24 years old. I waited, and waited, and waited there by myself. And finally, the nurse came out, and she had tears coming down her face. And she said, can you please come back into this room?
是的，是的。这真的只是为了完成一项测试看看是什么样。24岁，23，24岁。我独自在那里等着，等着。最后，护士出来了，眼里含着泪水。她说：能请你回那个房间吗？
And to say that my stomach dropped-- I could hardly stand up from the chair because I was so shaken. Walked back into the room. He was sitting on the chair, crying. There was a doctor in the room, a nurse in the room, the one who was crying. And he said, my test came back positive, through sobs.
说我的胃掉下来了——我几乎无法从椅子上站起来，因为我太震惊了。走回房间。他坐在椅子上哭。房间里有一个医生，一个护士，就是那个在哭的护士。他说：我的测试呈阳性。他哽咽着说。
I remember there was like a little stool in the corner that I sat down on. I just didn't know anything. I had not been prepared for this moment.
我记得角落里有个小凳子，我坐下了。我什么都不知道。我根本没为这一刻做好准备。
The doctor told Clay that since he had been having unprotected sex, he likely had HIV too. It was just too close to exposure for it to show up on the rapid test.
医生告诉克莱，因为他们一直进行无保护的性行为，他也可能感染了艾滋病毒。距离暴露时间太近，无法在快速测试中显示出来。
What do you remember feeling like when you got the news?
你记得得到这个消息时是什么感觉吗？
I really remember thinking, of course. Of course this is what's going to happen. Because just when you stick your toe outside of the church and you're like, OK, am I maybe going to do something? Like I said, I still really believed it. It's not like I closed up the Book of Mormon and was like, cool, that's not real. Bye, I'm gay. I still was like, oh my gosh, they were right.
我真的记得想：当然了。当然这会发生。因为就在你把脚尖伸出教会门外，觉得：好的，我是不是要做点什么？就像我说的，我仍然深信不疑。我并不是关上《摩门经》就想：酷，那不是真的。再见，我是同性恋。我仍然觉得：噢，老天，他们是对的。
To Clay, the cruel irony of getting HIV with his first real boyfriend wasn't lost on him. The doctor took blood samples and sent them home to wait a week for the results. The next few days were hell.
对克莱来说，与第一个真正男朋友感染艾滋病毒的残酷讽刺并没有被他忽略。医生采集了血样并把他们送回家等待一周的结果。接下来的几天简直是地狱。
And that's when I said, we're not going to sit at home waiting it out. We're going to go do something. And we're going to go do what I want to do, which is I want to go to New York City, and I want to see musicals.
那时我说：我们不会坐在家里等待。我们要去做点什么。我们要去做我想做的事，那就是去纽约市，去看音乐剧。
Clay spent nearly all the money he had on two flights and a cheap hotel. They got to New York and started getting as many $20 rush tickets to musicals as they could afford-- Spamalot, Jersey Boys.
克莱几乎花光了他所有的钱买了机票和便宜的酒店。他们到了纽约，开始尽可能多地买20美元的音乐剧抢票——《火腿骑士》、《泽西男孩》。
I was so excited by it all. I was so excited to see shows. I was so excited to be in the city, but also terrified. And it was kind of like these moments of elation side by side with these moments of terror as I tried to just ignore what was actually happening.
我对此感到非常兴奋。我看到演出非常兴奋。我身处这个城市非常兴奋，但也感到恐惧。当我试图忽略正在发生的事情时，这就像是兴奋时刻与恐惧时刻并存。
What was actually happening was that Clay was on the phone during the day, trying to get them both in a medical trial for HIV meds. This is what he was thinking about as he was waiting in line to see another bouncy musical, The 25th Annual Putnam County Spelling Bee. The doors opened. They shuffled into the theater. Their tickets were standing room only, so they hung in the back against the wall.
正在发生的事情是，克莱白天在打电话，试图让他们俩参加一个艾滋病毒药物的医学试验。他在排队看另一部轻快的音乐剧《第25届普特南县拼写比赛》时就在想这件事。门开了。他们挤进剧院。他们的票只有站票，所以他们靠在后面的墙上。
And the show ended, and we were all walking. You're all kind of herding outside. And we end up standing next to some people as we're herding outside, and they struck up a conversation with us, what appeared to be this gay guy and his friend, this woman. And they said, are you from out of town? And we said, yeah, we're in New York visiting.
演出结束了，我们都在走。大家都挤到外面。我们在挤到外面时正好站在一些人旁边，他们和我们搭了话，看起来是一个同性恋朋友和他的女性朋友。他们说：你们是从外地来的吗？我们说：是的，我们来纽约访问。
And by that time, we'd gotten outside of the theater. And he said, you know, you look like you were enjoying that show more than anybody in the expensive seats. And he pulled out a wad of cash. And he said, here's $200. Go buy yourself tickets to Sweeney Todd tomorrow. It'll change your life.
那时候，我们已经走出了剧院。他说：你知道吗，你们看起来比那些昂贵座位上的人更享受那场表演。他掏出一叠现金。他说：这是200美元。明天去给自己买《理发师陶德》的票吧。它会改变你的人生。
And I'm this kid from Utah. And I'm like, OK, what do you want? I was a little bit like, what's going on?
我是来自犹他州的孩子。我当时想：好的，你想要什么？我有点困惑：怎么回事？
Yeah.
对。
And I took the money, and I just was like, thank you. Thank you so much. You're really just giving me this money? And he said, yes, just take the money, as long as you promise you'll buy yourself tickets to that show. I was like, yes, yes, I will.
我拿了钱，只是说：谢谢。太感谢了。你真的只是给我这些钱？他说：是的，拿钱吧，只要你保证会给自己买那场秀的票。我说：是的，我会的。
And we were standing next to an ice cream truck. And I said, can I buy you an ice cream cone to say thank you? So we bought ice cream cones. And I asked also if I could take a picture with them because, again, I just couldn't think of what to do or say. I was so taken aback by it. That was a lot of money to me.
我们站在冰淇淋车旁边。我说：我可以买个冰淇淋球来表示感谢吗？所以我们买了冰淇淋球。我顺便问能不能和他们拍张照，因为我确实不知道该做什么或说什么。我太吃惊了。那对我当时的生活来说是一大笔钱。
Yeah.
对。
I could have done a lot of things with $200 at that time in my life.
那时的我可以用200美元做很多事。
They saw Sweeney Todd the following night. If you don't know the show, it's really different than the other musicals Clay had been seeing all week. It's about a barber who's seeking revenge on society by slitting the throats of his customers. His partner in crime, Mrs. Lovett, takes the bodies and bakes them into meat pies. It was nothing like the shows Clay knew from BYU. For Clay, it was like that moment in the movie Pleasantville, where the whole world is in black and white, and suddenly you see a red rose.
他们第二天晚上看了《理发师陶德》。如果你不了解这部戏，它和克莱那一周看过的其他音乐剧真的很不同。它讲的是一个理发师通过割断顾客的喉咙来向社会报复。他的犯罪伙伴洛维特夫人把尸体做成了肉馅饼。这和克莱在杨百翰大学知道的演出完全不同。对克莱来说，这就像电影《欢乐谷》中的时刻，整个世界是黑白的，突然你看到了一朵红玫瑰。
That was the kind of theater I wanted to do. It was weird. It was dark. It was strange. Some people hated it, and some people loved it. That's what I wanted to do.
那才是我想要做的戏剧。它怪怪的，很暗黑，很奇怪。有些人讨厌它，有些人喜欢它。那才是我想要的。
I wanted experimental, weird things. And this was experimental and weird. And they were pouring buckets of blood around. And Patti LuPone played the tuba. It was like it ignited something inside of me that was always there and that I knew was there. But it was like, oh, that's it. That's the thing I love.
我想要实验性的、奇怪的东西。这就是实验性的、奇怪的。他们四处泼洒血桶。帕蒂·卢波恩吹着大号。这就像在我内心点燃了某种一直存在且我知道它存在的东西。但那种感觉是：噢，原来是这样。那就是我热爱的东西。
So this random guy became for you a plot point in your life, where you basically were like, OK, there's the day before I met him, where I wasn't going to pursue any of this. Then I meet this guy and what?
所以这个随机的家伙对你来说成了你人生中的一个情节点，你基本上是觉得：好的，在我见到他之前，我是不打算追求这些的。然后我遇见了他，然后怎么了？
And suddenly I'm going to move to New York and be an actor, because this is what I want. He gave me permission to move on to the next step.
突然我要搬到纽约去当演员，因为这就是我想要的。他给了我进入下一步的许可。
Because he was like-- and by being kind, he basically was saying it's safe on this side.
因为他——通过行善，他基本上是在说：这一边是安全的。
Yes. That's the perfect way of putting it.
是的。这是形容它的完美方式。
The very next morning after seeing Sweeney Todd, Clay and his boyfriend got a call from the doctor saying that the rapid test results were wrong, that neither of them had HIV. For Clay, it felt like a sign. His impulse to move to New York, it was the right one.
看《理发师陶德》后的第二天早上，克莱和他的男朋友接到医生的电话，说快速测试结果错了，他们两个都没感染艾滋病毒。对克莱来说，这感觉像是一个征兆。他搬到纽约的冲动是正确的。
So he did, a year and a half later. He's been in New York for almost 15 years. And he actually did become a Broadway star. He's currently starring in Company opposite Patti LuPone, who he once saw play the tuba. And Clay still thinks about that guy who gave him money to see Sweeney Todd.
所以他一年半后搬了过去。他在纽约待了快15年了。他确实成了百老汇明星。他目前正与帕蒂·卢波恩在《公司》中演对手戏，那个人就是他曾经看过的吹大号的演员。克莱仍然会想到那个给他钱看《理发师陶德》的家伙。
Recently, he decided to do an act of kindness in the stranger's honor. He posted their story on Instagram, including the picture of them in front of the ice cream truck, and offered to buy tickets to Company for someone who couldn't afford it. A friend immediately called and said, I know that guy. They called the stranger over FaceTime. His name is Mark.
最近，他决定以那个陌生人的名义做一件善事。他在Instagram上发布了他们的故事，包括他们在冰淇淋车前的照片，并主动提出为负担不起的人购买《公司》的票。一位朋友立刻打来电话说：我认识那个人。他们通过FaceTime联系了那个陌生人。他叫马克。
So Mark.
所以马克。
Hey, Clay.
嘿，克莱。
I'm sorry. I'm going to get a little emotional. 15 years ago, I went to go and see The Putnam County Spelling Bee. And I was standing in the standing room.
抱歉。我会有点激动。15年前，我去看《第25届普特南县拼写比赛》。我站在站位区。
No way. No way.
没可能吧。没可能。
And I walked outside the theater, and you gave me $200 to go see Sweeney Todd.
我走出剧院，你给了我200美元让我去看《理发师陶德》。
Yes. How the fuck did you connect this?
是的。你他妈是怎么把这个联系上的？
Clay tells him how he ended up moving to New York because of it, how he's now on Broadway. It's a mushy, cathartic reunion.
克莱告诉他自己是如何因为那次经历搬到纽约，如何现在成了百老汇明星。这是一次温情而宣泄的重逢。
I don't even know what to say, but it's just so amazing that you remembered that, that actually-- sometimes you do things, hoping a random act of kindness will actually resonate with somebody. And that it actually did is really just amazing. What a gift you've given me today.
我不知道说什么好，只是真神奇你还记得那个，那确实——有时你做事情，希望一次随机的善举能真正引起别人的共鸣。它真的做到了，真是太神奇了。你今天给我的真是最好的礼物。
Oh, are you kidding?
噢，你在开玩笑吗？
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, of course.
当然，不用客气。
Clay has heard this recording many times. But when he plays it for me, his reaction is visceral. His face turns red. He's crying. What is it about a random act of kindness that does this to us?
克莱听过这段录音很多次。但当他放给我听时，他的反应是内在的。他的脸涨红了。他在哭。随机的善举到底有什么魔力让我们变成这样？
Like Clay, I can't talk about the strangers who've helped me without being reduced to a puddle. I think it has to do with the fact that it feels so unearned. Like if a family member or a friend does something for me, I understand it, because they love me. They care. But if a stranger does it, it breaks my brain a little. That's what I think is happening to Clay.
像克莱一样，我无法谈论那些帮助过我的陌生人而不变得泪流满面。我想这与它感觉如此无端有关。就像如果是家人或朋友为我做点什么，我能理解，因为他们爱我，他们关心。但如果陌生人这么做，它会让我的大脑有点短路。我想这就是克莱身上发生的事。
It's weird to be so emotional about something that's so happy. It's a great thing. It's all happy. I don't know why I cry about it. It's like I cry about it because it's like I believe in something again.
为如此开心的事情而如此激动真是奇怪。这是件好事。全是开心的事。我不知道我为什么要为此哭。就像我为此哭是因为我再次相信了什么。
Like it makes you feel like a little kid or something?
就像它让你感觉像个小孩子之类的？
Yeah.
是的。
Like hopeful or--
就像充满希望或者——
Yeah. Because it's-- I mean, along the lines of this conversation, it's when you leave a church that has been your whole life, you start to feel like it means you can't believe in anything anymore. And when something really incredible and good like this happens, it makes you believe again.
是的。因为——我是说，顺着这次谈话的思路，当你离开一个曾经是你整个生命的教会时，你开始觉得这意味着你再也不能相信任何东西了。而当真正不可思议的好事发生时，它让你再次相信。
By the way, I called up Mark, asked him why he gave Clay the money all those years ago. To explain one of the biggest reasons, he told me a story about this time he went to Italy. He had planned to stay with a new friend who'd recently moved to Rome. But the guy totally flaked on him, and he had nowhere but expensive hotels to sleep.
顺便说一句，我给马克打了电话，问他为什么多年前给克莱钱。为了解释原因之一，他给我讲了一个他去意大利的故事。他本打算和刚搬到罗马的新朋友住在一起。但那家伙完全放了他鸽子，他只能睡在昂贵的酒店里。
Mark didn't have that kind of money, so he called up this gay couple he had met his first night in Italy-- they ran a bar in town-- and asked them if they knew of a cheap hostel. Their response? Come stay with us.
马克没有那么多钱，所以他给刚到意大利第一晚遇到的同性恋夫妇打了电话——他们在城里开酒吧——问他们是否知道便宜的旅馆。他们的回答是：过来和我们住吧。
For 10 nights they hosted Mark, a complete stranger. Mark says they were total gentlemen, trusting him in a way that frankly shocked him. They gave him keys, told him he could come and go as he pleased. He couldn't believe their generosity. And it changed him into the kind of guy who hands a stranger $200 and says, "Hey, go see this show. It'll change your life."
他们接待了马克这个完全的陌生人10晚。马克说他们非常有绅士风度，那种对他坦诚相待的方式让他感到震惊。他们给了他钥匙，告诉他可以随心所欲地进出。他无法相信他们的慷慨。这把他变成了一个会给陌生人递上200美元并说“嘿，去看看这场戏吧，它会改变你的人生”的家伙。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. This is one of the songs in the show that Clay is doing on Broadway right now.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制片人之一。这是克莱现在在百老汇演出的剧目中的一首歌。
[MUSIC - "ANOTHER HUNDRED PEOPLE" BY STEPHEN SONDHEIM]
（音乐——斯蒂芬·桑德海姆的《又来了一百个人》）
Act 3, "Never Hear the End of It." So we close out today's show with this story that is very on point with everything we've been talking about till now from Sean Cole.
第三幕，“没完没了”。所以我们以肖恩·科尔的这个故事结束今天的节目，这个故事非常符合我们到目前为止所讨论的一切。
This is one of my favorite stories to tell. I tell it at parties or to anyone who will listen. And since we're here talking about the nature of people and whether they're mostly good or mostly bad, I figured I'd tell it to you. Have you ever seen A Clockwork Orange, the Stanley Kubrick movie-- guys running around in bowler hats and jockstraps on the outside of their pants, committing acts of, quote unquote, "ultraviolence?" It's one of the most iconic films of the 20th century, set in a dystopian near-future where teenage hoodlums speak this stylized, Russified slang. It's also intensely violent and deeply misogynist in ways I don't think I understood when I first saw it and obsessed over it. I was in my teens then, the same age that the main character Alex is supposed to be.
这是我最喜欢讲述的故事之一。我会在聚会上讲，或者对任何愿意听的人讲。既然我们在这里讨论人的本性以及他们是好人还是坏人，我想我还是讲给你听。你看过《发条橙》吗，斯坦利·库布里克的电影——在那群穿着圆顶硬礼帽、裤子外面穿着护裆、进行着所谓“超暴力”行为的家伙？这是20世纪最具代表性的电影之一，背景设定在一个反乌托邦的近未来，那里的少年暴徒说着这种风格化的、俄罗斯化的俚语。它也充满了强烈的暴力和深层的厌女症，我并不认为我第一次看到并迷恋它时真正理解这些。那时我还是个少年，和主角亚历克斯的年龄设定一样。
There was me, that is Alex, and my three droogs, that is Pete, Georgie, and Dim. And we sat in the Korova Milk Bar trying to make up our rassoodocks what to do with the evening.
那就是我，亚历克斯，还有我的三个好伙伴，彼得、乔治和迪姆。我们坐在牛奶吧里，试图决定晚上要做什么。
The thing is, the meaning of the story, what it says about the inherent goodness or badness of people, has been largely and grossly misunderstood, or at least the meaning that was originally intended by its creator, Anthony Burgess, the guy who wrote the novel the movie's based on. He talked about this a lot in his lifetime.
问题是，这个故事的意义，关于它所说的人类内在的好与坏，在很大程度上被严重误解了，或者至少被它的创作者安东尼·伯吉斯——写这部电影原型小说的男人——最初的意义误解了。他生前经常谈到这一点。
Although Kubrick made an interesting film out of it, the film wasn't quite accurate. He didn't follow the book as he should have done. He cut out the final chapter, for one thing.
虽然库布里克拍出了一部有趣的电影，但电影并不准确。他没有像他应该做的那样遵循原著。他删掉了最后一章，作为一件事。
The final chapter, chapter 21. The film is actually really faithful to the book until that last part. But that last chapter radicalizes everything. If you know the movie, you know the movie. But if you don't, you at least need to know the plot of it for any of this to make sense. I'll try to summarize it as quick as I can.
最后一章，第21章。电影在最后一部分之前确实非常忠于书。但最后一章将一切激进化了。如果你看过电影，你就知道。但如果你没看过，你至少需要知道它的情节才能理解这一切。我会尽量简短地总结。
So Alex and his three droogs, meaning friends, they spend their nights getting hopped up on drug-infused milk and hurting people. They beat up a panhandler, steal a car, and run other cars off the road. There's a pretty famous rape scene, which incidentally was inspired by Burgess's first wife getting assaulted, though not sexually, by a group of American soldiers. About a third of the way through, Alex accidentally murders someone during a break-in and goes to prison. And after serving a couple years, the government chooses him for a new experimental type of aversion therapy.
所以亚历克斯和他的三个伙伴，意思是朋友，他们整晚都在喝加了药的牛奶，伤害别人。他们殴打乞丐，偷车，把别的车撞下路。有一个相当著名的强奸场面，顺便说一句，灵感来自伯吉斯的第一个妻子被一群美国大兵袭击，虽然不是性侵。在三分之一的地方，亚历克斯在破门而入时意外杀了一个人，进了监狱。服刑几年后，政府选择他进行一种新型的厌恶疗法。
He'll do.
他行。
They give him this drug which makes him basically allergic to violence. Any time he so much as pictures hitting someone, he's overwhelmed by nausea and dread, also whenever he hears the music of Beethoven, but that's another thing. Then the government does this presentation where they trot out the new forcibly reformed Alex, subject him to insults, injury, sexual temptation, and in response all he can do is gag and retch. Then a priest in the audience leaps up to object with the operative word--
他们给他用了这种药，让他基本上对暴力过敏。任何时候只要他想到打人，他都会被恶心和恐惧所淹没，每当他听到贝多芬的音乐也是如此，但那是另一回事。然后政府进行了演示，他们牵出了被强行改造过的新亚历克斯，让他遭受侮辱、伤害、性诱惑，而他的反应只能是干呕。然后观众席里的一位神父跳起来反驳，用了关键的词——
Choice! The boy has no real choice, does he? He ceases to be a wrongdoer. He ceases also to be a creature capable of moral choice.
选择！这个男孩没有真正的选择，对吧？他不再是个作恶者。他也就不再是一个具有道德选择能力的造物。
Padre, these are subtleties.
神父，这些都是微妙之处。
Anyway, Alex gets out. A bunch of bad stuff happens. He tries to kill himself. The government sees the whole thing as a PR nightmare and gives him an antidote to the treatment, transforming him back to his evil, remorseless, smashing-things self. Also he can listen to Beethoven again.
无论如何，亚历克斯出狱了。发生了很多坏事。他试图自杀。政府把整件事看作公关噩梦，给了他治疗的解药，把他变回了那个邪恶、没有悔意、破坏东西的他。而且他又能听贝多芬了。
I was cured, all right.
我治好了，好吧。
The end. It's bleak with a point that it's better to let people choose to be bad than to brainwash them into harmless robots, clockwork oranges, with no will of their own. But in the book, the final chapter that wasn't in the movie, it changes the meaning of everything that's gone before it.
结束。这是一个暗淡的结论，认为让人选择变坏总好过把他们洗脑成无害的机器人、发条橙，没有他们自己的意志。但在书里，那个电影里没有的最后一章，改变了之前发生的一切的意义。
In the final chapter Alex is back at the Korova Milk Bar with three new droogs, whole new gang. But this time when they go out to stomp on random people, Alex hangs back. Something's eating at him. It's like he's bored with all the violence now, doesn't enjoy any of this like he used to.
在最后一章，亚历克斯带着三个新伙伴回到了牛奶吧，全新的团伙。但这次当他们出去践踏随便什么人的时候，亚历克斯退缩了。有什么东西在啃噬着他。就像他现在厌倦了暴力，不再像过去那样享受这一切。
He wanders into a coffee shop where he runs into a member of his old gang, Pete, and Pete's wife. They look happy, living the quiet life. And Alex thinks, maybe that's what's missing. Maybe I should settle down, have a kid, hopefully a son. "I felt this bolshy big hollow inside my plott," he says, meaning his body. "Feeling very surprised too at myself. I knew what was happening, O, my brothers. I was like growing up."
他游荡到一家咖啡店，碰到了他旧团伙的一个成员，彼得，还有彼得的妻子。他们看起来很幸福，过着安静的生活。亚历克斯心想，也许这就是缺少的东西。也许我应该安定下来，生个孩子，最好是个儿子。“我感到身体里有一个巨大的空洞，”他说，意思是他的身体。“也对我自己感到非常惊讶。我明白发生了什么，噢，我的兄弟们。我就像是在长大。”
When I read that, it was like the top of my head blew off. Alex isn't inherently evil. He didn't just go back to doing all the bad stuff he used to do. And he didn't need an experimental drug to reform him. He just needed time to get there on his own. I was in my early 20s when I picked up the novel, so some years after I saw the movie. And the feeling was like I'd unfairly underestimated someone for a long time.
当我读到那段时，感觉头盖骨都要掀开了。亚历克斯本质上并不邪恶。他没有仅仅回到过去做坏事。他也不需要实验药物来改造他。他只是需要时间自己达到那个阶段。我20出头时读到了这本小说，也就是我看电影几年后。那种感觉就像我很久以来一直不公平地低估了某个人。
It's also an ending that comports more with reality. There's research that shows a big reason people disengage from gang life is just that they get older, age out of it. But more than that, the two endings represent two completely different ways of looking at the world. One is saying that people can change, even the worst people, whereas the other is saying that evil is evil, irredeemably.
这也是一个更符合现实的结局。研究显示，人们退出帮派生活的一个重要原因是他们变老了，年龄让他们自然脱离。但不仅如此，这两个结局代表了看待世界的两种完全不同的方式。一种是说人们可以改变，即使是最坏的人，而另一种是说邪恶就是邪恶，无可救药。
And those two worldviews, they're baked into this ridiculous backstory about that final chapter. According to Burgess, when the book was published here in the States, the publisher told him they wouldn't put it out unless they could cut chapter 21. This was way before the movie was optioned. It was still just a novel. They said the optimistic ending was Pollyanna-ish, naive, and bland.
这两种世界观都嵌入了关于最后一章的荒谬背景故事中。据伯吉斯说，当书在美国出版时，出版商告诉他，除非能删掉第21章，否则他们不会发行。这远在电影选项之前。那还只是一本小说。他们说乐观的结局是波利安娜式的、天真且平淡。
They were like, we Americans are tougher than you Brits. We can handle a nihilistic ending. Some people are just beyond hope. That's more realistic. Burgess needed money back then, he said. If the only way to sell the story to Americans was to lop off its conclusion, then so be it.
他们说：我们美国人比你们英国人坚强。我们能处理虚无主义的结局。有些人就是无药可救。那更现实。伯吉斯说，他当时需要钱。如果把故事卖给美国人的唯一方式是砍掉它的结论，那就随它去吧。
So now there were two Clockwork Oranges in the world with two different endings depending on where you lived. Burgess writes about this whole mishigas and how he felt about it in an introduction to a later edition of the book. I just want to read-- this is probably my favorite part of what he says.
所以世界上现在有了两个《发条橙》，根据你居住的地方有不同的结局。伯吉斯在书的后期版本的前言中写到了这一切纠葛以及他的感受。我只想读——这可能是我最喜欢他说的部分。
"Now, when Stanley Kubrick made his film, though he made it in England, he followed the American version and, so it seemed to his audiences outside America, ended the story somewhat prematurely. Audiences did not exactly clamor for their money back, but they wondered why Kubrick left out the denouement. People wrote to me about this. Indeed, much of my later life has been expended on Xeroxing statements of intention and the frustration of intention while both Kubrick and the New York publisher coolly bask in the rewards of their misdemeanor. Life is, of course, terrible."
“现在，当斯坦利·库布里克拍电影时，尽管他是在英国拍的，但他跟随了美国版本，所以对于美国以外的观众来说，故事结束得有点过早。观众并没有确切地吵着要退钱，但他们奇怪库布里克为什么要删掉结局。人们给我写信。事实上，我后来的生活大多花在复印我的意图声明以及意图挫败的声明上，而库布里克和纽约出版商却冷静地沉浸在他们不端行为的回报中。生活当然是可怕的。”
It's funny, but it was also endlessly frustrating to Burgess. He wrote that he didn't think the American edition and thus the movie was a fair depiction of human life. It's as inhuman to be 100% evil as it is to be 100% good. The two need to coexist. He was unequivocal about that.
这很有趣，但对伯吉斯来说也同样令人沮丧。他写道，他不认为美国版本以及电影是对人类生活的公平描绘。100%邪恶和100%善良一样，都是没有人性的。两者需要共存。他对此毫不含糊。
Further, when the film came out, there was a moral panic about it, both in the UK and here in the States. And it wasn't just the violence people were upset about. It was the ending. An editor for The New York Times wrote in the Arts and Leisure section of the paper, "The thesis that man is irretrievably bad and corrupt is the essence of fascism." I can't help but think how all of this might have been different if that last chapter had never been cut.
此外，当电影上映时，无论是在英国还是在美国，都引起了道德恐慌。让人们不安的不仅仅是暴力。还有结局。《纽约时报》的一位编辑在艺术与休闲版块写道：“人是无可救药的坏和腐败的论点，是法西斯主义的本质。”我禁不住想，如果最后一章从未被删，这一切会有多大的不同。
And that, for years, was everything I knew. But then recently, as I was getting ready to tell all of this to you, O, my brothers, I thought I should actually do some research, make sure I got my facts straight. And as with A Clockwork Orange itself, it turns out there's a whole other chapter to this saga, one that I didn't know existed. To start with, that quote from Burgess I read earlier that ends with "Life is, of course, terrible."
这就是我多年来所知的一切。但最近，当我准备把这一切讲给你听时，噢，我的兄弟们，我想我应该真正做点研究，确保事实正确。正如《发条橙》本身一样，事实证明这段传奇还有另一整个章节，我之前并不知道它的存在。首先，我刚才读到的伯吉斯的那段引语，以“生活当然是可怕的”结尾。
That's a very entertaining account of the story. I think it's inaccurate in various ways.
那是对故事的一个非常有趣的陈述。我认为它在各个方面都不准确。
This is Andrew Biswell. He's spent more than 25 years researching Burgess in part for his aptly titled book The Real Life of Anthony Burgess. It wasn't always the easiest job.
这是安德鲁·比斯韦尔。他花了25年以上的时间研究伯吉斯，部分是为了他那本名副其实的书《安东尼·伯吉斯的真实生活》。这份工作并不总是最容易的。
He would embroider, and he would be more concerned with telling a good story than with sticking to factual accuracy. Now, I'd been going through the manuscript of A Clockwork Orange as part of my research into Burgess.
他会润色，他更关心讲一个好故事，而不是坚持事实准确。现在，作为我研究伯吉斯的一部分，我一直在查阅《发条橙》的手稿。
The original manuscript, the one Burgess sent around to his editors in England and America.
原始手稿，伯吉斯寄给英国和美国编辑的那份。
And just turning the pages and noting any annotations on the typescript. And I remember coming to this note in his own handwriting, which says at the end of chapter 20, "Should we end here?"
就是翻看页面，记录打字稿上的任何批注。我记得看到了他自己笔迹的这张纸条，在第20章末尾写着：“我们要在这里结束吗？”
"Should we end here? An optional "epilogue" follows." "Epilogue" is in quotes. Again, this was at the end of the second-to-last chapter, where Alex turns bad again.
“我们要在这里结束吗？可选的‘后记’随附。”“后记”加了引号。同样，这是在倒数第二章末尾，亚历克斯变坏的地方。
And what did you think when you saw it?
当你看到它时，你是怎么想的？
I nearly fell off my chair. I was very surprised, because I'd grown up with the Burgess introductions and commentaries on his book. And up until that point, I'd been inclined to believe them. And this question, "Should we end here?" I was surprised by the level of doubt.
我差点从椅子上掉下来。我非常惊讶，因为我是伴随着伯吉斯对他的书的前言和评论长大的。在那之前，我倾向于相信它们。而这个“我们要在这里结束吗”的问题，让我惊讶于怀疑的程度。
Surprised because Burgess publicly was so emphatic that he had been forced to cut the last chapter and that it was the wrong decision. And when Andrew looked into it further, he found that Burgess's editor in America, Eric Swenson, never insisted on scrapping the last chapter. Yes, he thought it was Pollyanna-ish and, quote, "unconvincing," but getting rid of it wasn't a condition of publication.
之所以惊讶，是因为伯吉斯公开场合如此强调他被迫删除了最后一章，而且那是个错误的决定。当安德鲁进一步研究时，他发现伯吉斯在美国的编辑埃里克·斯文森从未坚持删掉最后一章。是的，他认为那是波利安娜式的，引用他的话，是“不令人信服的”，但删掉它并不是出版条件。
Not only that, this guy Swenson said Burgess agreed with his opinion and that Burgess told him he'd only added the 21st chapter because the British publisher wanted a happy ending. Also Burgess wrote his own screenplay for A Clockwork Orange that ended at the same place Kubrick's screenplay did, no redemption. And then years later, Burgess wrote a musical, yes, a musical version of the story, which reverted back to the longer redemptive ending and took it even further.
不仅如此，这个叫斯文森的人说伯吉斯同意他的观点，而且伯吉斯告诉他，他添加第21章只是因为英国出版商想要一个快乐的结局。此外，伯吉斯为《发条橙》写了自己的剧本，结束的地方和库布里克的剧本一样，没有救赎。然后几年后，伯吉斯写了一部音乐剧，没错，故事的音乐剧版本，回归了更长的救赎结局，甚至更进一步。
Alex goes off with his girlfriend, and they're going to get married.
亚历克斯和他女朋友走了，他们要结婚了。
Oh!
噢！
That's right. Yeah.
没错。是的。
Is she a character, or is she offstage somewhere?
她是一个角色，还是在台下某个地方？
No, no. She appears and speaks. She's called Marty.
不，不。她出现了并说话了。她叫马蒂。
[LAUGHS]
（笑）
And then the play has a prologue in the Garden of Eden, where Alex and Marty play Adam and Eve. It's very confusing. The whole thing is messy. It's strange that he tries to pin this on other people, whereas the reality is that it's like the good angel and the evil angel are dictating sort of different endings to him.
然后剧本在伊甸园有一个序幕，亚历克斯和马蒂扮演亚当和夏娃。非常令人困惑。整件事很混乱。他试图把这个归咎于别人真是奇怪，而现实情况就像好天使和坏天使在向他灌输不同的结局。
So in the end, which ending do you think that Burgess thought of as the better ending?
所以最后，你认为伯吉斯认为哪个结局更好？
By the time you get to the 1980s and he's making his stage adaptation, he's coming down in favor of chapter 21 as the correct or the authorized ending.
到了1980年代，他改编舞台剧时，他倾向于支持第21章作为正确或授权的结局。
And what does that say, do you think, about his worldview, like about what he believed about the true nature of human beings?
你认为这说明了他的什么世界观，比如关于他所相信的人类的本质？
Well, the big thing that had changed in his life was that he had a son by his second marriage and a very wayward son. He was, I suppose, worried that this person should do well in the world. Yeah. I suppose Burgess in the '80s, he's much more of a protective father figure.
嗯，他生命中最大的变化是他与第二任妻子生了一个儿子，而且是一个非常叛逆的儿子。我想他担心这个人能否在世界上有所作为。是的。我想伯吉斯在80年代，更像是一个保护性的父亲形象。
Which, if that's the reason, makes so much sense. When you have a kid, especially one you're worried won't turn out well, you have to believe people can change like Alex finally changed, dreaming of his own son. It's like they literally ended up on the same page, Burgess and Alex. One of them happened to have typed out that page while the other danced across it in a jockstrap and suspenders. They both grew up.
如果这就是原因，那就太说得通了。当你有一个孩子，特别是你担心他将来可能不会变好的时候，你必须相信人们可以改变，就像亚历克斯最终改变时梦见他自己的儿子一样。就像他们最终在同一页上一样，伯吉斯和亚历克斯。其中一个人恰好打出了那一页，而另一个穿着护裆和背带在上面跳舞。他们都长大了。
Funnily, Andrew Biswell says he prefers the shorter ending. Just thinks it makes for a tougher book, although he goes back and forth, he says. Depends on what day you ask him.
有趣的是，安德鲁·比斯韦尔说他更喜欢那个短的结局。他觉得那样书更硬核，虽然他说他会反复纠结。取决于你哪天问他。
Me, I come down where Burgess ultimately did. I like believing that we can grow into better versions of ourselves. And besides all that, you get to see Alex walk off into the sunset. On the last page he says, "Farewell from your little droog." Should we end here?
至于我，我支持伯吉斯最终的选择。我喜欢相信我们能长成更好的自己。除此之外，你还能看到亚历克斯走进夕阳。在最后一页他说：“告别了，你们的小伙伴。”我们要在这里结束吗？
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
[MUSIC - "TRY A LITTLE KINDNESS" BY GLEN CAMPBELL]
（音乐——格伦·坎贝尔的《尝试一点善心》）
Our program was produced today by Elna Baker. The people who put our show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Chris Benderev, Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Kyla Jones, Tobin Low, Michelle Navarro, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Will Peischel, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Alissa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Nancy Updike, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu.
我们今天的节目由埃尔娜·贝克制作。今天组建我们节目的人包括比姆·阿德武米、克里斯·本德列夫、佐伊·蔡斯、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、凯拉·琼斯、托宾·洛、米歇尔·纳瓦罗、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、威尔·佩舍尔、纳迪亚·雷曼、瑞安·鲁梅里、阿丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、南希·厄普代克、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Thomas Reid. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 700 episodes for absolutely free. Also there's videos. There's lists of favorite shows, if you're looking for something to listen on a long car trip. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。今天特别感谢托马斯·里德。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，在那里你可以完全免费播放我们700多集的档案。还有视频。如果你正在长途旅行中寻找可以听的东西，那里有最喜欢节目的列表。再次声明，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He went this week to a Gwen Stefani concert. His review?
《美国生活》由PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他这周去看了格温·史蒂芬妮的演唱会。他的评价？
I was surprised by the level of doubt.
我对此感到非常惊讶。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。